[Music]
by their barrels here and you've been
selected to be part of the bear grylls
survival academy the mountain between us
experience congratulations
no no it's we're not we just met the
ladies of eat erupted out of the woods
for two days for Bear Grylls outdoor
survival experience channeling the
mountain between us Co stars Idris Elba
and Kate Winslet
you really hurt your leg the phone
smashed my phone has no signal and we're
pretty high up on the mountain
first up ziplining through the Catskills
okay so when you're ready off you go
okay fearless okay next our victim I
mean volunteer happy five let's go we
stay here we're safe if we leave search
and rescue they're less likely to find
us build a shelter between the two of
you so think about the wind direction
because maybe it's getting cold you
light a fire you get the wind direction
wrong the smoke will flow into the
shelter prick test before we go though
what the rule of threes we can go three
weeks without food three days without
water and three hours without shelter
protection is essential one part
protection is fire you're going to learn
how to make fire no lighter no matches
and who knew you could build a fire from
scratch with a tampon and knife but we
definitely weren't ready for this kind
of dinner
now it's dirty now our challenge is on
what would you do
I am barbaric you are crunching through
bone
Thanks
this river is rising fast move fast come
on the go we got to go earlier because
River now back to civilization or at
least safety for the Knights and where
else come for packets of almonds a
couple of candy bars
laughing in sangwich there's some
cookies
[Music]
after a long day one here's what Bear
Grylls had on the menu so who wants to
participate the Bear Grylls and if that
wasn't enough try rappelling down a
100-foot waterfall diet today
so here's our scenario your images
you've got to save her
nobody knows where we are you all we
have is me and you do you actually think
we're gonna make it we're gonna get down
the mountain your world pal
she's a touch to you so you gotta trust
that her life is in your hands always
got so I don't want to die up here
because you're too scared to take a risk
that's it it goes well done dogs it goes
great job go us
and then the final challenge was to swim
it through that ice cold water we're
freezing but it was great this whole
weekend's have been a great experience
[Music]